good morning everybody and welcome to
the plans committee at the 7th of
october
and those of you who may be watching on
youtube and then later on
first thing i'll do is ask
the committee and then the officers who
were present to introduce themselves and
start with himself and councillor
chrysler that i chaired the meeting and
i'm
good morning my name is peter christie i
represent a bit of a norm
good morning i'm i'm richard bowsen i
represent heartland award
pete watson i represent rhodey
good morning rosary lock i represent two
rivers and three walls
good morning members shaun harrington
planning manager
good morning i'm stacey dorey head of
legal governance
good morning i'm tracy blackmore i'm
development management team leader
um we've got sandra our clark now who
takes a minute and we've got tom who's
to blame if everything goes wrong with
the central side
and on the end i think we've got a
visitor from north devon council if
that's right yes
yeah welcome
claire do you work on the planet's
committee
right okay
here's an answer
right okay
i don't want his apologies for absence
please
thank you chair yeah we have one apology
councillor wiseman councillor pennington
substituting
item two on the agenda is the minutes of
our last meeting and they're on page
5 to 11.
the meeting held on the 2nd of september
i'll move those minutes from the floor
council watson
i'll second it
thank you councillor
yeah uh
we'll go through the votes on that one
please
thank you chad
councillor
councillor brown
councillor christie or cancer craigie or
councillor leather four councillor or
councillor watson or
councillor pennington abstain
thank you
item three on the on the generous deck
council christopher can i just ask um on
phase seven of the minutes
phase seven at the bottom of the pager
um i did ask about the section 106
agreement and it said it says that devon
county had to be contacted to advise him
on the committee's preferred scheme we
heard any more about that
sure
uh council christie we have contacted
evan campbell i'm advised that we have
had a response
right okay item three on the agenda is
declarations of interest
members with interest to declare should
refer to the agenda item and describe
the nature of their interest when the
items being considered
elected members of devon county council
and the town and parish councils who've
considered a planning application by
virtue of their membership of that
council called a personal interest and
are deemed to have considered the
application separately
and the express views of that council do
not bind the members concern
who consider the application of fresh
item four on the agenda is agreements of
agenda between parts one and two of you
would know part two
on the agenda
item five is urgent matters
uh i'm nothing
nothing from the planning manager
six is public participation
uh
and here's where i advise the members
of prior requests to speak
my members of the public with three
uh well four actually to speak to the
duck haven corner robot the first one
was martin wilson on behalf of the
parish council
the second speaker speaking against is
philip marlowe
and then councillor
pennington uh will speak as the ward
member
for montlia and huckford
but will take no part in the decision
making on this application
and also council of laws
will speak because it is for adjoins
uh this ward
very close but it's right alongside so
i've said that he can speak to it as
well there's the board member from
westwood
those are the speakers
[Music]
right seven on the agenda is the
planning applications
the information and recommendations and
advice
contained in the reports are correct at
the date of preparation which is more
than 10 days in advance of the committee
meeting
due to these time constraints any
changes for necessary updates to the
reports
will be provided in writing or orally at
the committee meeting
and then we go on to our first
application 7a
one of link zero eight double five
complete 2021 full application
and tracy blackmore is a planning
officer
who will give us a presentation on this
application tax trades thank you chair
can everyone hear me okay yeah yeah yeah
so yes this is application reference one
slash four eight five 0855-2021-4
[Music]
this is the full application for change
of use from multi-use building to a
single holiday lens and external changes
to support a micro wedding business
i just have one very quick verbal update
um and that's to note that council
pennington had also called in this
application if the recommendation was to
refuse the application
as they call it any student the officers
were minded to refuse this calling
hasn't been noted on the uh committee
report but i would like to obviously
admitted that councilman pennington had
also
requested a call-in for the application
that's one of the verbal updates we have
so just going on to the first slide so
this is a location plan with the sunset
room buildings and access tracks in the
east
outlined in red and the applicants other
land ownership identified in blue
the application site forms part of the
duck haven stud enterprise which is
located to the west of westwood home
the site is run under the name of
westwood living which is offers 14
self-catering holiday lets the site is
also running as established wedding
venues since 2013. this aspect of the
business is related to this application
next slide
this is a block plan where the sunset
rooms annotated on the plan
outlined in red and members will also
see the ocean cave building to the
southwest also annotated on the plan
both these buildings are used in
connection with the wedding business
so next slide please
this is an aerial image and sunset rooms
again are indicated with the red arrow
the site is a designated area of
outstanding natural beauty and within
the coastal estuarine zone
a public right away consisting of the
southwest coast path runs along the
western boundary of the site
next slide
so just moving on to some photos mental
will then as we'll recall we had a
virtual site visit last week so they
should be sort of fully briefed on the
site but i will just go through some
quick photos just to sort of recall
members of the site
so this is the front elevation of the
sunset rooms
and next slide please
so just another photo of the sunset room
within the surrounding context of the
site and the blue arrow indicates where
the car parking area is proposed the
users of the building
next slide
this is another view of the sunset
buildings and shows the building sits
behind a large grass area with expansive
beams outside the sea
next slide is again another photo taking
the front of the sunset rooms and shows
that adjacent grass area and the view
out from the paper scene
and this shows the existing interior of
the sunset rooms which is obviously the
subject of this application as members
can see this is an open function room
capable of coding large events um there
was a video taken last week so um of
this buildings and members are aware
of the interior
next slide just for context this is a
photo of the ocean cave building which
is also used in conjunction with the
wedding business
and the next slide is just a sort of
context so this photo shows the sunset
building on the left which is the
subject of the application and its
relationship with the ocean cave
building on the right um and both are
gonna both these buildings are used for
the wedding business
so next slide is a photograph taken from
the southwest coast path again members
will remember my video um walking along
the southwest coast path and
panning up to the site um so the south
west coast path as i said runs along the
western boundary of the site and the
building is set back as such the
building is not visible from that
southwest coast path and i just have
another food chain again taken from the
southwest coast path indicating again
you cannot see the building from the
public right away and that just
indicates that private footprint site
which just lays onto the site from the
southwest coast park
so just moving on to the proposal
the proposal as i said is the change of
use of the multi-use building to a
single holiday actually some external
changes which i will go into detail into
this presentation
so the first slide shows elevation
drawings on the front and rear of the
sunset rooms
so the drawing to the left is the
proposed elevation and the right isn't
existing elevation
so the proposed examination alterations
include the installation of a timber
deck balcony with non-reflective glass
balustrading and an external staircase
to access the barricade
the installation of five timber windows
the stained glass to the southern
elevation
and the installation of eight aluminium
frame circle hole reflects the roof
the next slide please
this is the west elevation again the top
is the existing and the bottom is the
proposed the top drawing demonstrates
the west elevation and the timber deck
as is and the
the bottom drawing is the proposed
elevation with the timber deck balcony
and you can also see that external steel
staircase to the decked balcony
um next slide please so our new members
wanted to sort of drill down last week
um
the actual measurements um
of the existing building and or the
proposed balcony and temple deck area so
i can confirm that he's annotated on
there but i will it's a little
he's not that well on the slide so the
existing height of the building is
2.325 meters
the timber depth balcony level is 0.67
meters as you can see from um the slide
obviously the lesser the measurement
goes less as it goes back and in terms
of the sloping of the existing roof
and the balance trade is shown as 1.1
meters
which the agent has confirmed is a
minimum requirement for building control
in terms of compliance um
and so the overall height of the
building will increase from 2.3 meters
to 4.1 meters so hopefully that confirms
to members of those measurements
so the next slide is the east elevation
drawing so just the other side again
demonstrating the proposed um to the
bottom is the proposed balcony area
and the next slide
so this is the proposed roof plan
demonstrating the installation of the
eight aluminium frames circle roll roof
lights to the roof
and the next slide is an indicative
image of the jewelry and demonstrating
the propel spoke in the area and the
eight roof lights proposed to be
installed
the next slide is an existing and
proposed floor plan of the sunset rooms
so the right the image to the right is
the existing floor plan showing a large
open plan function room and the image to
the left demonstrates the proposed
integrations to include six bedrooms and
the ones that have been the large dining
and lounge area
so moving on to the planning
considerations
so the principle of development your
offices would not wish to prejudice the
continuation of the wedding business
being operated from the site
it is clear it is the applicant's
intention to continue the wedding
business with a slightly different
business model from large-scale weddings
to micro weddings to adjust to the
market situation and rebuild the
business in light of the kobe 19
pandemic
the change of use of this building will
hopefully support this new business
model for a micro wedding business it is
clear that ocean cave would need to
function as a venue for wedding
ceremonies and the sunset room for the
wedding breakfast and guest
accommodation
therefore as members will see in my
recommendation and conditions i'm
suitably worthy condition is recommended
to ensure that the ocean cave is only
used for civil ceremonies as a wedding
venue
and the previous commission in 29 19 is
effectively swapped so the sunset
building is used as the holiday
accommodation
in light of the uncertainties resulting
from the kobe 19 pandemic and the
adverse economic economic impacts upon
the wedding industry
this is considered a reasonable
compromise to support this wedding
business
so the visual impact and landscape
character
the proposed external alterations have
been outlined to you
the proposed timber deck balcony has
non-reflective glass so will not appear
out of keeping of the existing sunset
buildings which as members have seen
primarily consists of full-length
glazing to the front elevation
the glazed balcony would essentially be
transparent and would not appear out of
place with this brave lace building
in respect to the installation of the
eight roof flights your officers have
noticed concerns noted concerns raised
by the aomb partnership in relation to
lightspill
this is an important consideration in
the arv for ecological impacts from the
tranquility of the site and that is
recognized
however it has also recognized there is
an established building on the site
the existing building has
extensive fully glazed doors and
therefore this additional
uh roof light would not significantly
alter that situation and the impact on
the air b
your officer has a condition attached to
condition requiring details and
specifications of the roof lights and
any proposed internal lighting
this has also been conditioned to ensure
that no external lighting is to be
installed
in the building or on the site
the site it has to be recognized lies
within an extremely sensitive location
designated as an aob
the
national planning policy framework
advises great weight should be given to
conserving and enhancing landscape and
the ceiling beauty to the amv
your officers consider that the proposed
would not lead to material harm to the
landscape of the aomd and will combine
with relevant policies of the local plan
and the nppf
just skipping on to impact on immunity
the any third party properties are
located significantly away um to ensure
that there is no significant harm to the
amenities of any neighbouring properties
highways and parking the sign and access
statement confirmed the proposing will
decrease the number of traffic
and traffic movements to the site
the proposal is therefore considered to
have a positive improvement to safe
highway safety and surrounding network
in terms of drainage uh the foul
drainage should be done with existing
septic tank the council's environmental
protection officer has no objections to
this
and the last one ecology it has been
concluded there will be no effect on
protected species or habitat as a result
of the scheme
so in conclusion the proposed change of
use and associated external changes is
considered acceptable contributing to
sustainable social and economic growth
in the district
subject to appropriately early
conditions it is not considered that the
proposal will result in substantial harm
to the designated sensitive landscape so
my recommendation to you chair is of
approval
thank you thank you thank you tracy for
that presentation
if alaska can vacate the table but we'll
want you back at the end of
public contributions to answer questions
before we get our first speaker in
somebody'll come and wipe the tablet
every school
my lovely wife
right
our first speaker to this is
martin wilson on behalf of montlick
parish council
is he here
he's submitted
his contribution was submitted because
he cannot attend
and was going to be read by the planning
officer well there's nothing oh yeah
sorry
yeah sorry yeah it's down
here um all right thanks sean yeah if
you're happy for me to reach here
absolutely
members if you can't hear me let me know
enough yeah speak close to the
microphone
this is a statement from martin wilson
and it states
unfortunately i cannot now attend the
planning meeting on 7th october sorry
could you use them
is that better members
yeah
a statement from martin wilson
unfortunately i could not attend the
planning meeting on 7th october due to
having to self-isolate prior to eye
surgery on the 10th of october
however i would be grateful if the
problem could be read out at the meeting
this application was considered by the
parish council on the 28th of july 2021
and an objection submitted to torres
street council
in summary the parish council objects to
this proposal as a change of use within
the and b to holiday use would set a
precedent for any other sizeable holiday
developments within the aimb
stringent conditions to severely limit
any further new development site must be
set and enforced so as to both preserve
the natural beauty of this particular
area and indeed to discourage any
disfigurement within the much-loved aomb
martin wilson chairman paterson parish
council
thank you
[Music]
thank you uh sean now our next speaker
is
philipp marlow a member of the public
speaking against the cause
when you get settled um
mr morrow you've got three minutes to
address it
good morning committee
i'm a forty year resident of abbotson
and supporter principal of aonps
planning policy states that a major
development in an aonb should only be
permitted when there is a proven
national interest and no alternative
site outside the aonb is available
duck haven is a major and successful
development but it would not have been
approved 25 years ago
if an application had been submitted
covering everything that has since been
developed
it has grown through a series of small
steps
first stables and agricultural buildings
next accommodation for group
grooms because it was an agricultural
business
next the conversion of stables and
grooms accommodation to holiday lands
because they were now redundant
agricultural buildings
the first non-approved agricultural
application was for the ocean cave as a
small low-key wedding venue
this was followed by the sunset room
in the case for the sunset room was that
it was needed to make the ocean cave
business viable
various stages the aonb called for an
overall plan of the site but without
success
we now have an application for change of
use of the sunset room to holiday
accommodation
to make the business viable because
large-scale weddings would no longer be
held
however there will be large-scale
weddings
i know of three in the current week
and if there are large weddings past
experience suggests
that there is every possibility of a
further application for a sunset room
type business to make the ocean cave
holiday business viable again
i can understand the officer's
recommendation because the application
doesn't require new building
and conditions have been proposed to
stop further growth and ensure continued
local employment benefits
i would contend the committee has to ask
are those conditions strong enough to
stop the sunset room being let as a
holiday home the largest percentage of
the year and reducing the economic
benefit to the area of the existing
holiday business wedding business
secondly should the owners not be asked
to sign up to a long-term plan site
precluding incremental further
development
duck haven has grown by itself and
become a large development
which should not have been located in an
aonb
on this poem basis i oppose the
application
without stronger conditions precluding
further development on that site thank
you mr chairman thank you committee
thank you mr marlowe thank you
did i make my three minutes spot on
right the next speaker then it's kind of
councillor pennington used to speak yeah
council pennington was to speak as a
warrant
there's no time limit to you canceling
anything i'll be shorter than three
minutes chair thank you very much just
some background thank you chair um thank
you tracy blackwell for your
presentation um very well presented um i
have only been board member for apertum
um since may 2019 due to the boundary
changes and i read the length of
planning applications that's gone down
on this site is nearly two pages on on
your report back so there's been an
awful lot in the past
from the position i think i would not
normally have called this in to support
the application
um because it is in an area of
outstanding natural beauty
however
each application i believe must be
judged on its own merits
so therefore looking at what was put
before us
there is already an existing building
there there is a slight raise to the
balustrade at the top with glass that
will hardly be seen from the situation
and given that the immunity value will
improve because it appears there'll be
less traffic dropping there i feel on
balance a business should be able to
develop where it's within the framework
of the local plan and i felt there was
enough argument within the local plan to
make the case for the development to
continue
i would not object if you put in
stronger reasons and i'm very close to
the worst that mr marlowe actually spoke
before but we're slightly on two sides
of the very narrow fence i suppose on
this one
but i feel that on balance i would like
to see the application approved and
granted and because it allows the
business to change in the light of all
the changing situations it is an
improvement in the immunity situation
and i can rest assured that should have
been inside the aonb any other
development that seek to develop things
on a wider scale i would not call it in
to approve so i asked committee to
consider this and
following on from what the officer has
recommended that this application be
granted thank you chair for your time
thanks for coming thanks councilman
bennington
i think you'll have to just leave the
room now please that's right yes
and then we'll call you back
[Music]
[Music]
thanks sarah and then our final speaker
is board member from westwood hall which
adjoins this state
councilor nick laws from west virginia
my concern well no first of all i have
great sympathies with the applicant
because cobia has devastated all sorts
of businesses
in different ways
no more than their type of business
i really just have one
question which i'm hoping will be asked
by the members
and that is
if this is granted
does it weaken the case of the aanlb
should an application come in for
further
uh um
holiday legs on that side will this set
a precedent
that is really my question
uh and i'll be very interested to hear
the answer because you've seen the
nibbling effect of a multitude of
planning applications
and one
one can only ask will it be further and
will this week in the case there nobody
which is just so important thank you
chad thank you council lovers
[Music]
any questions
[Music]
okay
right talk to the committee comment from
the commission counselor
um
yeah just as well two questions in
points
designed an accent access statement in
detail with great interest and i do
approval with the business that it's
going to restructure itself after brexit
and the pandemic i do not agree entirely
with all the statements made in that
design and access statement
um
with regard to the traffic flow
movements i mean this
if it is granted and it can be let to 12
people it could mean six cars visited
every time it's net it could be left for
52 weeks of the year
so i don't really see how the traffic
number of traffic
movements would be
reduced because i don't well i don't
actually know how many weddings they had
in the past few years but you know they
would only arrive once and leave once or
whether reception so i don't really
agree with that and can i ask
also in the um design and access
statement um
the agent said that the kobe 19 pandemic
can be considered as a material
consideration with significant weight is
that correct
thank you remember um
it can be a consideration uh the way to
be put that consideration is for the
decision taker um so it would be for
members to exit the weight
right and just carrying on then from the
officers you pulled um
i know that abbott parish council object
and i think captain law is objectively
the same reason that it might set a
precedent for a future application but
we all know sitting on plans committee
that is each application on its own
merit so you can speculate whatever you
like
but you can't pre-judge what is going to
come in
um a northern town council of jets
um because of the adverse effect on the
aonv
but the aomb say that some of their
concerns have been addressed
but they would um not support any
further applications from this site
but natural england state that
development will not have any
significant adverse impact on the
protective nature so that's a plus
um if we are minded to approve the
application
i would like to see an additional
um condition
and that relates to no street furniture
that is taken chairs are allowed on the
tip of the deck balcony with the glass
of addition any time
because although you know the stairs
look awkward
there's always the means of getting
things up and i'd hate to think that
people sat out there
nighttime like that so if we do grant i
candles
at
would like to see that extra condition
yeah um
and also with regard to the condition
about the weddings
um
phase 26 condition four
should could the condition read emotion
and micro weddings not just weddings
otherwise they might
i think that's important because that's
the whole idea of changing this so they
can change their business plan to
enlightenment and microwaves i think
those words will be included in
condition four
could you say that again
based on
to what other accounts uh what other
community members have got to say but at
the moment i'm likely to
want to approve of the application
thank you council a lot councillor
christie
yeah thank you
well i called this in uh
it must be
pretty unusual for two councils to call
in one if it's accepted one if it's
rejected but um i called it in because i
see i saw that both parish councils who
are involved are objective and the iomb
which is pretty unusual and i thought
this needs discussion nothing else
um
what intrigued me was when i looked at
the four pages uh council penton
mentioned two pages of applications
actually four pages if you look at page
15
of our agenda
third from the bottom construction
multi-use building this is the sunset
rooms is withdrawn
and i thought well when did it get
planning division this is not on our
list and it's only when you go back to
the original
uh list of applications you suddenly
realize
the application for the sunset rooms
isn't on the list
and that is very interesting because if
you go back to that all the original
points and i can quote the number if you
want to find it but it's not on our list
which is
you know rather unexpected i thought did
it actually have planning permission
originally
it did
but it's not on our list which is now i
went back to the original application i
read through it and this stressed the
fact that as we heard from mr marlow
that
the sunset rooms were needed to make the
cave economically viable and if you look
back at the original application there
is a note from the applicant which is
heading need for the venue and it says
the ocean cave wedding business needs an
all-weather structure to accommodate
wedding caterers and receptions
so the two are very closely linked
we know that this was built merely
because the cave was operated
yeah apparently now that doesn't apply
and i hear about code bit
but
that was short term i mean every
business in torridge could quote that
really
you know oh we've been hit by kobe can
we just change your views and do
something else so it's not really a very
strong
thing and i i hear what sean has just
said that it's up to the council
um
the other thing is i've read a lot about
micro weddings and enlightenment
weddings and all this but that's not
what the application is for
it says very clearly on our documents
this is for a holiday let
it's not for anything to do with the
wedding it's a holiday lent and council
lockers just mentioned this could be you
52 weeks of the year
and if you go back to the original
application one of the reasons this was
granted was it would be intermittent use
there wouldn't be constant
movements of cars it would be constant
light and sun and yet this we all know
holiday lakes can be 12 months
um
that worries me a lot actually
the last thing is the roof lights
because
all right there is an existing building
it does have blaster trunk but
they want to put in eight roof lights
and the air b is picked up on this
uh and saying you know this is now gonna
have lights going up in the sky because
lights don't stay i've read in there
they're going to have a downward point
inside but we all know that lights will
go up and i think we should actually
make that much stronger i'm not even
sure the roof light should be there if
this is past but there we are
as it stands
uh
as councillor pennington pointed out
when he says the two pages are actually
four pages of piecemeal development
and it does worry me this is yet another
piecemeal development that we've heard a
lot says this will come back later
and be changed again yeah it does worry
me entirely and i cannot see
that the cave can still function really
without this sunset rooms and to say it
can be a holiday that you're instantly
divorcing the two buildings
thank you
thank you councillor christine
uh
councillor craig
i'm
concerned that litecoin that
the to have a wedding business you've
got to do catering and you've got to
give them refresh
from various places
is there another site on this with more
than multiple other buildings but where
they could do that
or i mean i know that the aov say they
don't want marquees because i can see
that you can get beautiful wedding
monkeys but they're huge
i can see that if they're going to have
a rating
they're going to be picking up
markets have we got any control over
them
we can add an additional condition i
well
following on really from what councilor
christie said i do remember the original
application for this building as a new
build when it was first built and the
strong argument made was
it was integral with the wedding
business with the wedding cave
and that was the reason
this location
uh
in the aomb was permitted at the end
because of the economic benefit of the
business which was the weddings taking
place in the ocean cave so it was
strictly for uses weddings there in this
building it was for receptions and
that's all it was for
and then further on they got a change of
use
that they could use it for any large
gatherings parties anybody could hire it
for any kind of party
so it was changed from being a purely
wedding venue to abuse multiple uses it
says now multiple use
but it's correct that this now will be
if it was granted a holiday there plain
and simple
and reading a lot of the paperwork
objections and
a letter that kathy murdoch has put in
it's been a very successful business as
a wedding venue i know it's been
interrupted as all businesses have
with the uh virus over the last 18
months
all businesses have been very successful
up to them
uh hosting i made something like 160
weddings
now
if this goes ahead and is converted
to a holiday
where will they hold any receptions for
any weddings and they talk about smaller
scale 35 to maybe 60 yes
well i can't see that you could
accommodate those inside
the holiday that if it's converted your
holiday there when you look at the plans
there's a table there for what
10 people 12 people to set up
so would they be coming forward and
wanted large marquees up in the grounds
completely you know negating the use of
the building that's there now
the other thing that does concern is
this balcony
because whilst as tracy said it's not
visible currently
from the
coastal graph will it be once that
overall
1.77 meters is stuck on top of the room
i mean part of the original decision to
build it because it's been built was to
make it as unintrusive as possible this
is going to add to it being very
obtrusive
so i'm not happy about the bulking on
top of it
and again as council christian said how
do you stop people putting tables and
chairs out from there and sitting out
there
late into the evening if it's a holiday
that you wouldn't be able to control
so
i'm very
ambivalent about
granting this one but tracy perhaps you
can answer that there's additional
height on top of the room
you reckon it won't be visible now from
there it wouldn't be visible from the
southwest spacecraft pretty sure that
additionally
federal
[Music]
when this building was first
given planning permission
it was
spoken of because it's in the omv about
the views from out of in the day items
you can see looking back and that again
is one of the reasons it was kept to the
height hit saturn and unobtrusive it did
add
to the obtrusiveness of the building
looking up on the top uh
anybody else what did they go to
council
yeah
somewhere in in our agenda there there
is
some uh states about the marquis
and um for the lightning i can't find it
in a minute chad do you want me to come
back on the floor
so there is a condition that removes
parts
[Music]
that's condition five my recommendation
i mean obviously we can put a stronger
word condition if you want to actually
specify marquis intense
i'm sure we have
the flexibility to do that
that would have to be
um
also i can't quite get my head round why
they need to have um
the roof lights in
is that is that basically
for to cover over a bedroom
so that it gets right into your bedroom
as you see the interior of the building
obviously it does rely heavily on the
front um elevation being fully glazed so
further back very less natural light
coming in
obviously if you are subdividing the
building um into bedrooms and a lounge
area you will need that natural light
coming in
because otherwise it would be very dark
so there are five windows to be
installed to the rear which wouldn't be
seen anywhere else facing up to the
quarry
and then we maybe move lights
um
to the roof to allow that natural light
in again as i say there are conditions
to ensure that any lighting
we will have a look at in any details
um
can i come back on a couple of points
that members have
pretending it might be helpful it might
not be i think we do have to recognize
that the asian cape building has
permission to be used as a holiday there
and that hasn't sort of come up but we
are effectively swapping the ocean cave
being used
to the sunset rooms being used
um in terms of chancellor locke's
condition about no street furniture
allowed on the balustrade i think that's
a reasonable condition that we can add
into any recommendation
um
i think
there certainly is the appetite for
micro weddings i don't know i don't know
much about weddings but i certainly
can't see that in light of coco 19 there
is much more of a
preference for rather than larger
weddings more like weddings um i think
in terms of the catering issue
there is going to be just one chef who
comes in and there is two kitchen
facilities for him or her to cook
um
and i think that could be accommodations
on set rooms
um
yeah did that if there's anything else i
can help with then obviously yeah sean
and i will help them yeah
i haven't quite finished
sorry
could you put the
slider with the um with the balcony
please tom
are you
that's basically open
and
it tony tony has to the
glass upon on the outside of it which is
obviously has to be so really people
could run all over that roof
somewhere
so why why is he not encased in all
together
and you
without having to use the roof
and the lights
uh i'm not happy about having these
these lights and i'm not happy about the
balcony
um i'm
not sure that we should i'm not sure
that we should approve this
carry-on chair thank you councillor
watson jason did you say that wedding
cave is
the asian cave mission 2019
can i just ask
how many people are going to be housed
in the ocean okay now is the holiday
left
so i don't think it was actually ever
converted from having a look um so there
are obviously before plans that would
have converted it to a holiday that
wasn't actually unconverted but they
will see his permission to have a
historic relationship to allow that to
happen
country brown
my main concern
is we have seen this development
myself get bigger and bigger so i would
like to ask the africans to put in a
business
plan and
we can see does that mean what the plan
is for this area
the other thing is um i don't like the
rules either
i don't like the stairs i have mobility
problems so there's no way that anybody
these problems could get up there at all
is there and the other thing i'd like to
say if i won't go past
we've lost
144
buildings to holiday nets in the last
year so i think we need to be mindful of
how many buildings we turn over to that
i've been listening to
members questions and tracy's responses
as well there's just a few things that
i'd just like to clarify for members
which may help members
um there'll be no net gain in all their
uses um or holiday accommodation as
we've just discussed will be swapping an
existing permission which could be
implemented um
it's also worth mentioning that the
officers are supporting this application
because it's seen as a way of supporting
a existing business and diversifying
that
there is um a converted bond elsewhere
on the site which is used for receptions
so they still do have that
which will be linked with this
in relation to the roof area if members
felt um it was needed we could add an
additional condition um stating that
only the timber declare you can see how
indicative
in front of you is used um and also go a
step further and that there's a
additional value across the back of that
to prevent that use and that would be a
reasonable condition
in relation to the adding the words of
micro wedding and elopement in the
condition
a test conditions are that they'll be
precise i'm not convinced that would
meet that test
just because of definition i don't know
what the definition of micro wedding is
my definition may differ from your
definition and then to chat and force
that would be difficult um i think we
need to put their number on that if you
use them to uh members who are wishing
to do so
um
and finally
as it has to be mentioned we do assess
each application on its own merits um
yes there has been a long history on
this site however we have to assess this
allocation on its own merits and not on
relation to what this may bring um
you've seen the a and b responses and
the second response on station responses
and on that basis it's your officer's
recommendation to approve
a chair
thank you sean
[Music]
did you say did i hear you correct them
that
the the
[Music]
ocean cave
is
substituted
yes condition on this um on this
recommendation which requires that they
basically give up their planetary ocean
cave and it gets swapped to the sunset
rooms
well
condition four does mention
the ocean cave building
should only be used for civil service of
winnings
in accordance with the extent permission
day to date in march 2012
is the ocean came you've got giving up
this planning permission got to convert
it to a holiday
so they won't be able to do that yeah
that's correct and that's what the agent
can have confirmed
right okay
good job
[Music]
it's a mini honeymoon after the wedding
essentially all right
well i'm going to recommend approval um
with the additional conditions that i
mentioned about those office um street
furniture on the balcony and also with
regards to the balcony in the back um
at the trade
so people can't get on the roof
and so i will recommend approval with
that condition
what about the marquee once as well
agenda of what they intend to do there
yeah i think that's why that reason will
be nice um
they don't know what the future holds no
one knew about the brand
and if there'd be no pandemic perhaps
this application wouldn't be coming
forward so i do think that's rather
difficult for any
one who wants to go forward in the
future
the only reason i say that is because
aonb would like
right and so i think i think we should
go with it at least you know we should
go with the a and b in that and that
sort of situation but
and council brown has made that point
for mr morrow speaking also made the
point about an overall plan for the
staff i don't know
um
no
my advice would be that would be
unreasonable to do so
any future developments have come before
us there's a planning application in any
case so they'll be considered and
given circumstances it'll get reasonable
to ask a applicant to put in such a
business plan to support this type of
application
council christie yeah can i just ask one
thing about the go back to the lighting
again i've just been reading the
original applications and so on and
if you look on page 16 of our agenda
second from the top
discharge of conditions eight and nine
of the planet application there's the
that's the number of the original
application which doesn't appear in our
list
and that was refused and if you actually
read what that was about
number nine prior to the building hereby
approved being brought into its intended
use a scheme for the internal external
lighting the building shall be submitted
to and approved in writing by the local
planning authority yet the scheme they
put in with refused and it's never come
back
so is there lighting
i won't say illegal but
has it ever had any planning permission
has it ever come before has it done the
scene
good question
i mean
reading through through this and through
the conditions
five we want to mention inside about the
monkey if it's if this is going to be
graphic yeah but i've got to say
personally i'm still not happy with
these roof lights in there because there
are windows to be installed in all the
rooms that propose so
uh but i know from the the plan
these roof lights is which are quite
large when you look at the according to
the plan
but right over the top of the beds so
they can line them looking stars that's
the idea
but they are large and whatever down
lighting might be in the rooms like
spinach is unavoidable throughout into
the dark night sky so i'm not happy with
that because the building has got
windows to each of the rooms i also know
it looks like it looks
there's beds for 11 in there and not 12.
because one of the bedrooms is a single
bedroom
um they're a bit cramped in my view as
well
and the balcony i can't support that
balcony on the front
so
because of those two reasons i'm not
able to support this application
but cancer locks moves to prove it is
there any additional conditions
this is condition nine on the original
application
but you can see it was refused when they
didn't apply for discharge of that
condition it was refused it never seems
to have come back to us
i know these things can be lost but
that is quite an important aspect of
this
application
discharge of conditions 89 on that full
application in 2013.
the chair is that point i'd take on
boardwalk out to criticize that but is
that point valid for this application
well we need a new condition perhaps if
there is no light no permitted lighting
development in there would like to have
a condition
that is submitted
but there is a condition about lighting
this one condition the last condition
they
condition
yeah to do with external right
well this is lighting that
concerns me out through these big roof
lights
[Music]
you know it's
that should be a lot of lights for the
job through there into the darkness
condition seven does
ask details as an interior lighting
yeah
which we obviously would consult with
this church condition
to ensure they're happy with that
[Music]
fragration i
consider that argument slightly lost in
terms of that light spillage but i don't
want to do
because from a distance you could have
like it could have the effect of
spotlights going up into the sky for the
most reflections
[Music]
those details and specifications of any
interior lighting
that's condition seven yeah
the wording of condition seven is
exactly the same as the one that we
refused last time
which they never came back on uh are we
going to
prove it this time and nobody takes any
notice of it again
i mean charging why we refused it in
2012 um
okay well sean can't find that with a
minute so it looks like it never had
the lighting plans for the building
approved
council lock has moved to approve this
is anybody to set anybody
nope
come here another recommendation
i'll move that it's refused because i
don't like that balcony on there and i
don't like the roof
i think they're detrimental to the aonb
yeah
um just to remind members of the um the
code of practice for plans committee
if a member of the faculty is to move a
motion to refuse an application they
must provide full reasons for refusal
which must include a statement as to
demonstrable harm caused and a list of
the relevant planning policies which the
application is in conflict with
and statement of policies relevant to
the decision so members maintenance
would wish to consider that
okay if you want to use the uh
things i quoted when i called it in you
very well
are you ready we get your next 13.
so
sdn and sto14
sp149
i mean they've got
when i looked at these plans i could
never accept why they need that balcony
on the top because at the front of the
building there's a very large pirate
paved area anyway where you could sit
outside and casually
so i never could understand i want to
stick that right on top of the building
making it more
obtrusive than it already is and the
roof lights again
i don't believe there is a need for
those
and it for me it's detrimental on the
aomd
without those i would support converting
it inside
sorry jake can you just articulate the
the reason you said you mentioned
detrimental
because of light splits from the roof
members may wish to consider policy dm
o8a
in that incident as well as paragraph
176 of the mppf which relates to the
protection of protected landscape
thank you
those reasons
yes chair so um as i understood what
you've just said it's uh due to the
additional light spill um from the
proposal uh detrimentally impacting the
protected landscape of the areas
right so that
so margaret was changing
for a refusal councillor okay thank you
councillor christie or
chancellor craigie or
councillor leather or councillor lock
councillor watson four
that's six for refusal and one against
jeff thank you senator
[Music]
featuring
[Music]
want something
[Music]
[Music]
right uh our next
our next agenda is 7b application 1
0.031
2021 full application
this was
brought to committee because
councillor richard wise when
an elected member is related together
and uh
i'll plan the office of kissing easily
or give us a presentation
thank you
thanks chair um
so yeah i guess if we uh crack straight
on with this it's changing news about
cultural land to um caravan
park
and looking to the next slide it's
verbal update so
um the applicants emailed in and they've
asked that condition four be amended now
condition four was put on there because
abortion camera parts are really
complicated i'll try not to bore you too
much of jargon but if you approve the
caravan part there's nothing to say that
you can't put static caravans on there
um
so condition for the purpose of it was
to
attempt to avoid static caravans being
placed in the site and in my report you
see that because they would have a
greater landscape on the more touring
caravans would be especially in winter
months so
um
they suggested a different condition
which would work better for their
business plan
which would mean that um people could
effectively leave their touring caravan
on site throughout the entire season but
remove it in winter now
i don't have any objection to this
because the main landscape farm would
actually come over winter when there
wouldn't be
as much foliage on trees heteros etc
surrounding the site so um
i've suggested a slightly different
condition and which hopefully you can
see on the screens
i'll just leave mine because i think
it's better
no caravans most homes or tents shall
remain on site will be brought onto the
site between the 10th of november and
28th of february each time the year
any caravan or motorhome taken off site
during this period shall be removed from
the park in its entirety and the reason
is to limit the landscape palm which
will arise from exciting caravans on
this site over winter so my
recommendation has changed slightly in
that i would recommend this condition
substitutes condition for
it appears to work better for the um
and there's also another quick update um
0.6.5 in my report discusses drainage
there is a drainage problem on site
which is covered by condition seven i
just thought i'd update you um
because it indicates that the applicants
could um provide more information and
achieve a compliance condition instead
of a condition
which needs to be discharged
unfortunately they haven't uh got to the
point where we can have an updated
condition so condition 7
remains development condition and
there's no change so recommend that
is
goes forward with that condition
that's all for the update so if we uh
we'll do a tour of the site um
[Music]
here's the location plan it's um
very close to little torrington which um
you can just see the start of in the
sort of northeast corner
of the
um screen there and it's on the
great torrington to merton road um just
as you can't the hill round past
baseball um
or up that's where rosemont is down at
the bottom there's a long straight
couple bumps or something like i'm sure
most of you probably know it
um the existing caravan park is uh well
set within a sort of valley area
and this site is um
to the
north east and it's more of a hill so
it's bringing the caravan apart out of
the existing valley area which is the
reason for the condition
and that's it's mainly more poor if we
keep going down
here's the block plan now
the yellowed area is the top of the site
and in my opinion um there would be
significant landscape harm if caravans
were to be sighted on here so
the yellow area is
recommended that there's no
developmental exciting parameters on
that because of the uh how high that
particular part of the site is
um
but we can explain that more detail once
we've done a lap of the site
if we go down
is the error image just showing the
existing caravan part difficulty there
so that is
we can go down again
this is the entrance um
the red arrow points to where the field
is um you can see the existing caravan
park is fairly well tucked in there and
then the field is raising up and out
again
this is the displays this fence there um
i
asked the applicant to a headshare
because it would limit the views into
the site and uh there
they agree with this and there's a hedge
fund which we can discuss later
right keep going
and then and that's the view from the
other ways
this is going down the access
road
you can see the site there on the right
and just the farthest build okay
and then this is uh
we're going to go in an anti-clockwise
direction around the site so it's the
southeast corner looking across the side
to the west
southeast corner looking west down
through the existing caravan park
that's looking back towards the entrance
from the northeast corner so that's
travelling up the site
this is looking back down you can see
there's quite a long distance views
with the camera
downhill
it's live in the southwest again you can
see the existing caravan park and
london's views
this is from the top of the site looking
it's northeast corner still looking west
again you can see
how prominent the site is
and we're just looking over the hedgerow
country north
back to what you can just about see
little torrenting church and some houses
uh sort of the hedgerow there
you look really really carefully
there you go
thank you
and then this is looking uh southeast
gribble if you know that uh
sort of setting up
it's just a countryside hamlet river is
in the background
um
and then this is looking southwest from
the northwest corner of the site and
existing caravan parks below
so back to the proposed cycling
there's
as you can see the yellow area as i've
already discussed is proposed that
that's only used for tents and just
because of the performance of the site
there's a variety of petrol planting
here which will be secured by condition
down again
and there's a variety of sections you
can see the existing noun levels dotted
red so um
because they're quite steep they will
need to level the site
um so this is section a a and then on
the section drawing i've just included
each one with a red line so you can see
where the section is taken from
b b
c c
[Music]
and d dd
um with regards to the sections slaves
are due to be just grass banks which
would
it's not obvious it would have a lesser
impact than agave basket for example
viewed from a distance
this is the hedgerow plan so um
there's no changes proposed to existing
heteros
and it's proposed to plan new hedgerows
by the entrance which will scream that
from that highway and then there's some
heteros on site as well as shown in the
rock climb along with
some trees
then down
these the main uh planning
considerations principle
you can read them um
let me say them all
hopefully red markets are report
and i'm recommending approval subject to
second conditions
any questions
thank you chris thank you for that
presentation
i'll just ask a question
about the application itself because the
proposal for change of use
from agriculture land to caravan stroke
quality bar
to extend the existing holiday park
it's not just for tourism just for it's
not just for multiples
um
yeah so it is from my point of view it's
just for caravans maybe it's a poor
description i'm not sure so um i mean if
you want to extend it and put static
down to there they can
well
this is the whole point of the condition
condition for which would avoid
any static bands being placed on site
well when you look at the you know i'll
bring council lock in
when you look at the sections that we've
just shown then they're going to cut
into the field
permission so they'll be set down
they're all they're all works and from
the main room you can't really you
wouldn't be able to hardly see anything
um
and that's the baseball
i've been counseling
um yeah i was asked
chris i couldn't find anything in his
report about the size of the field or
what grade agricultural land is but
however i didn't travel through the
application form and if there's 2.4
north hectares can you confirm that
please chris
and what great agricultural agriculture
management okay thank you uh that's a
lot so yeah i would um
make presumption that the
uh size area in the application board is
correct however i have not included that
in my obstacle court and i have not done
a um exterior boundary check um
generally it's just a case of
getting the location plan in and going
off of that so i've received a site
location plan i've assessed it on the
basis of the location plan and what i do
and do not think is acceptable to put on
there
um the
grade of agricultural land and it is
good to moderate which is free and so
one is excellent two is very good three
is good to moderate four is four and
five is very cool and then there's two
more which
are basically urban um so
it's bank smack in the middle it's not
the best and most versatile which would
often be the
test there's nothing in the policy per
se which would require um
the best and the most versatile to be
retained whilst it would
often be
[Music]
this does have the principal policy
support um because it's
the extension of the existing
tourism facility so and even if it was
very good for example there would
probably still be policy support for
this phone
okay just one point another point i
didn't have
concerned about condition before but i
think chris is uh with the offended
conditions i thought um the three months
combined does that mean a continued
period of three months or is it three
separate months or if combined they
could have to stay for six months but i
think chris has
reworded the condition for satisfies my
concern
approval subject to the change of
condition
of second that's it
i i'd just like a bit of clarification
on what
why i was sticking just with mobile
caravans and camper vans i mean
i read this when i first read through
this i thought well they want to extend
what's the current
static caravan site and then maybe some
of those sites
would be used for motor homes touring
ones and again why the restriction on
november and february i mean people come
all the year round
homes with caravans most homes certainly
do
you know we're supposed to be supporting
a lot of these businesses and i can't
see why they get restrictions like that
especially when you look at the site
itself
and the fact that it will be cut down
into that steep field and the top part
of the field
is just for camping you know
whereas the rest of it is so i really
can't see why condition falls in there
at all
council craig
i just wanted to ask a question how much
does the site will be
tarmacked or concreted over because
i mean if it's
tense you can leave it as glass but if
it's the motorhome
it
and the landscaping is there any
landscaping within the site not just
around the site
i mean it's just going to is it going to
be like a car park
okay i'll answer
both questions so i'll start with uh
chair if that's okay so um
i'm not quite sure i understand
condition four i completely agree with
and that's the whole point of my
condition we have a
opportunity to try and encourage all
your tourism conditions
and that that's the reason for my
condition for now what i don't think
following myself is it is that this site
is suitable for static caravans okay
simply because it will cause significant
landscape time in my opinion
so condition four requires counts to be
removed
from the site
at
various points and and then not come
back so it'd be unfeasible for example
you just put a static caravan on there
leave it even if it's a maximum of six
months leave it for six months and then
have to remove it for six months of the
entire site
that's just not gonna work economically
and it's just not feasible so it would
be limited then touring cameras and the
reason they have to be removed from
sites because otherwise they could just
simply slide
the static caravan down a little bit and
then push it back up with the traffic
so so briefly i do think it's important
to have all year round tourism
accommodation and that's the whole point
of condition four is because it enabled
tourism condition all year round what it
prevented was someone putting a caravan
there all the way around them remove it
and bring it back if they wanted to
revisit and
so
that's the whole point of that condition
the applicants themselves have said that
doesn't work for their business
because they would have to
remove the caravan from site
uh and what they what we tend to want is
a seasonal pitch
so
they inform me that the park closes
generally from those dates so that's why
they've suggested those days i think
it's reasonable because it secures
effectively what i want which is
not uh no caravans there during the
winter period which would be the most
sensitive uh period for this particular
site given that um the lanes surrounding
site generally fairly um
they're fairly well
pushed up i can't do the word in the
winter i know you've added more in there
because you said the clothes are sad
you didn't say that but they're not
so obliged so that's the point of my
condition four they could have
and the landscaping issues that council
craig mentioned
um yeah so if we can go
if we can go back to the sections
[Music]
so i'm told that these banks and grass
banks and then the
areas
through and then we can see that i can
show you what it would be like so we've
got pictures of the
uh they've effectively done the same as
this below so it goes and scrolls the
photos
[Music]
yeah
so so it's leveled areas with a roadway
going through the center of the um
of the flat area so that you could um
access it and then each plot itself is
uh concreted with the
um
surfacing points on that plot so
i would anticipate it would look quite
similar to what's there as existing
um to the one below
in terms of drainage and surface
watering track i don't have any concerns
regarding
the runoff
into the existing site but i do have
concerns with balance drainage
i hope that clarifies so it looks like
there's a lot of
[Music]
[Music]
i would
attractive i think it would actually be
better than that
i think that's something that would be
reasonable with it if you're what you're
saying is there will be landscape farm
without um water trees the trees that
are on the block plan are mainly focused
upon one area so if we can go back to
the rock band
so we can see here that the trees are
mainly focused on the eastern edge um
and i don't think it'd be unreasonable
to also require trees around the
northern and western boundaries of the
site because that would again provide
additional screening
for the paramount park so if that was
something that you wish to achieve and
that was the reason for that um then i
think
we could add an additional uh condition
which required them to effectively
provide more details of tree planting
around the north
[Music]
i have in the past and it is very well
managed
and attractive science and it always
looks neat and tidy um so but because i
suppose chris as you well know it
depends on the definition of caravans
yeah how can we relate that to april
farmer dalton
it's very hard because it might be well
managed now it may not be in the future
so i think um but yeah i would agree
it's the landscaping that's existing
does screen apart quite well this
particular site doesn't have as good of
the landscaping
yeah
well translate you've moved in council
yes
would you are you happy with an
additional condition on some extra tree
planting did you submit yeah
[Music]
could you take the ball please cancel a
lot
moved it and cancer watson said
thank you chair council about it number
four
chancellor brown
chancellor christie or councillor
craigie or cancer leather or
counselor lock for councillor watson for
cancer pennington or
unanimous chair thank you sandra
thank you
my
a full application and it's here because
the land is owned by torres district
council thanks sarah
thank you chad can i
declare myself to your hatted we've had
this one at the time
council christians do that
thank you jeff
i said this is um been brought to plans
committee because it is on torres
district council land
so it is the creation of a compound to
include a kiosk unit concrete slab
replacement and a 1.8 meter high steel
palisade perimeter fencing and it will
be at the sports ground kingsley road
next slide
so as you can see the the location plan
shows the site edged in red the compound
isn't going to cover the whole site um
so
if you can see to the northeast is
morrisons and that's the car park there
um the south is the sports pitch and
then to the southwest is the skate park
next slide please
so this is what the proposed compound
plan is you've got the main kiosk unit
in green
and so it's 28 meters squared in total
and then you've got the fencing around
it and you've got the access gate going
into the site um
on that picture to the top is the the
existing wall that's already on site so
it's going to be bound up against that
wall
so these are just some photos to show
you the context of the site so this is
um from across the highway so kind of by
the morrison's car park entrance there
and looking out to the wall
so this is looking towards the site so
where the fence is that's where it's
going to be bound up against the wall
and back from the wall there so on that
kind of small area of grass there
that's looking at it from from the skate
park so
it'll be in
on the right hand side of that slide on
the grass verge with the fence on one
side obviously you've got the telegraph
hole there so it will be tucked in into
that corner
so this is just kind of panning around
the site to kind of give you the context
this is looking at where the access is
into the site
and then the next slide
so you've got the
garage there and obviously part of the
state park that's to the north west ham
around
again
so obviously you do have the residential
dwellings but they are quite a
separation from the site with the skate
park and you can go around again
that's the this mainstay park itself and
then the next slide
just shows you the perimeter of fencing
that's already at the skate park and
obviously that there's still going to be
grass verge for open space um for people
that are attending the skate park the
next slide
so this is the compound elevation itself
the kiosk is going to measure 3.2 meters
by 2.2 meters at a height of 2.35 meters
as already said the
fencing will be at 1.8 meters
um the kiosk they put in a powder-coated
steel green and that will be on the
concrete slab and then there will be
chippings around the site to
accommodate drainage with surface water
drainage
so the next slide just shows the kiosk
in its entirety
so as i've said the measurements have
all already been done there is um it
does say in the design and access then
decide an access statement and temporary
agreement this is a 15-year lease which
they're hoping to renew after every 15
years which is with our property team um
because obviously it's torres district
council land so they have already got
that agreement with them if this goes
through and they're obviously hoping it
will continue because it will provide um
jurassic fiber for
um
people of billy ford but it is on a kind
of continuous 15-year release with
torridge
the next slide
so the material planning considerations
for the application are the principle of
development the impact on character and
appearance impact on neighbouring
immunity ecology highways
it is in a critical drainage area so we
have had to consider that and then
obviously in conclusion we are
recommending it to be approved thank you
chair thank you
i've got no problem with this at all so
i'll propose that we approve it
thank you council watson councilman i'd
just like to ask about the goodwood
drainage area i haven't been any
flooding in that area in the recent
years and is there any protections we
should be looking at or mitigating any
any possible flooding risks in the
future
so devon county council flood risk
management team have been consulted they
have categorized it as a minor
development and obviously have referred
it back to
me as a planning officer obviously we've
had a look you have got the state park
there they are trying to mitigate it
with
um there's no tarmac or kind of
expensive um materials it is all
chipping so that any water that is
caused from surface water with the same
of the kiosk there that it will be
drained through those chippings um as
far as i'm aware there has been kind of
no flooding issues there with skatepark
and they have done as much as they can
to mitigate that
thank you
thank you so council boxing council
just on
the lighter side when i read the
description creation of the compound to
include include the kiosk units
um and the concrete lab etc i thought
kiosk i thought perhaps it was an ice
cream
if nobody else wants to make comments
councillor watson for approval
and council rock sending it
come and take the vote recently yes
thank you jan councillor
for councillor brown
councillor christie or councillor
craigie or councillor leather or
councillor or councillor or spencer
pennington or unanimous chad
sandra thank you
[Music]
which is the appeal decision summaries
on pages 45 to 54.
yeah
i have known on the agenda is costs on
appeals and there are no costs
10 on page 55 has the agm applications
which are dedicated
item 11 on the agenda
ages 56
to 68 our list of delegated planning
decisions
uh between the 20th of august
and the 23rd of september
i'll start with page 55
age 55.
yeah
one day
i was interested to see that they have
empty rock climbing missions to knock
down the old tool because we have side
business it was fun and games on that
side so i was quite surprised that i
went through that one
[Music]
good page 57
and it's 58
59
mid 60
with a couple of refuse funds
but again you see a number of
applications you've been dealt with that
period is
enormous really
[Music]
five past eleven i'll declare
dependencies
closed and thank